with ever greater pressure on budgets
comes ever greater scrutiny of the way
they're spent especially on the big
number EU backed infrastructure
educational or social projects smart
connected innovative and cross-border
are the keys to success according to a
parliamentary report in two ways to
improve results is la aplicación de la
Nova syren del desarrollo de rahe ho
tambien de la investigación en cuanto a
la realidad economica de cada ratio
llamo Sam estas en el amor de la see da
da da da soryo cidades de las Empress
archivo de reportar todo SU kre dairy or
NR a--'s a console estos ok TiVo's
regional development funding aims to
bring economic and social parity to all
members of the european union at
forty-three percent it swallows a big
part of the budget countries joining in
2004 and beyond have been the main
recent beneficiaries so highlight this
smart thinking actually look hola mas
por ejemplo de una cidade de la gente
estamos hablando de un transporte
publico cacia menos contaminant aim a
sustainable a ultra portable eco mucho
my rational depositor soma mentor allah
ye luminescent mr. val cartels report
his on Parliament's own initiative so
doesn't bind the commission to action
nonetheless its focus on regional
development as a driver of high quality
employment and intelligent city building
makes it hard to ignore em EPS will
debate and vote on the issue at this
week span recession
you